but as you try any other values i mean
our next uh prime number along i mean we
could either go with x equals two and y
equals five or we could go with um you
know x equals three and y equals five so
you're sort of hopping along
uh solutions are far and few between
things start to collapse and you're like
oh this is not this is not getting me
anywhere helpful at all and the reason
why this is i think you can sort of gain
some insight not just because you throw
numbers at it but because you can
actually try to understand what these
two sides of the equation are about
is that if you were to lock in a certain
value like let's say you know x was
going to be equal to 2 and then i'm just
going to try out all the other values of
y every other prime number right
if you lock that in and actually because
of this symmetry between x and y it
wouldn't matter if you locked in y and y
equals three and then just tried out
lots of other numbers for x right
as you test out different numbers just
by keeping one thing steady and then
changing the rest you will see why the
left and the right hand side at least i
think
can never be equal to each other after
this first solution the left and the
right hand sides not only do they not
equal the same thing they actually get
further and further apart forever as you
try different prime numbers so here's
the way i'm going to illustrate it as i
said before let's consider
what happens if x is stuck at two right
this is a classic mathematical
problem-solving strategy by the way when
you've got um something complicated and
there's lots of things changing just
hold one still and then vary a different
part of the situation i suppose it sort
of relates to the scientific method if
that's something you've learned about
like you are trying to control um a
situation as much as you can and just
just vary one thing and see like oh is
this the thing what what's the effect if
i change this is one thing and
everything else is the same and i can
observe the effect of changing that one
variable is what we call it and that's
exactly what i've got here
so i'm going to consider x equals 2 and
various values for y okay now i've
already tested out
y equals 3 so i'm just going to ditch
that
what i'm going to do is i'm just going
to consider y equals
5 6 7 8 9 ten and so on okay now let's
have a look here i'm going to compare
the left hand side which is going to be
uh let's actually just grab this
nope don't need all of it so
i'm going to have
get rid of all these colors we don't
need them anymore
[Music]
i'm going to consider this left hand
side versus this right hand side
when x equals 2 so it's going to be 2 to
the power of y plus y
and i'm comparing that to
y to the power of 2
plus 2. so you can see everywhere that i
had those x's here here and here i'm
just replacing them with twos and then
seeing what happens okay and i'm going
to start
oops various values for y i don't know
why i started i think i must have said y
equals 3 allowed and then
wrote it when i didn't mean to okay
so let's consider what happens to the
left hand side
and the right hand side should have
given one more row
when i try different values for y like
say for example uh five and then i'm
going to keep on going up okay
now even though i have this sort of
condition that uh y and x have to be
prime uh the pattern that i'm gonna try
and show to you it's actually a lot more
obvious if i include all the numbers not
just uh five and then the next would be
seven and then uh eleven and then 13.
i'm actually gonna go in sequence sort
of just up by one so i'm gonna go five
six seven eight nine ten etc because
there's a pattern i'm sort of looking
for um that i noticed when i was
fiddling with this which is going to be
easier to see if you have all the
numbers all together let's just go to 10
that should be enough okay
all right now i'm going to start with
the left hand side so i'm going to have
2 to the power of whatever y is and then
i'm going to add y okay so for this
first one here for the left hand side
i've got 2 to the power of 5 plus 5 to
the power of 5 plus 5. so 2 to the power
of 5 is
2 times 2 times 2 times 2 times 2
which is 32. you might wonder how i know
that and that's because um
powers of two uh something which people
who play with computers a lot happen to
know because binary uh makes things grow
and double like that so i'm gonna get 32
plus five which is
37.
next one along is to the power of six
that's 64 plus six which is 70 and then
i'm going to go 128 plus 7 so that's
135.
256 plus 8 which is 202
i'm doing this all mentally so if i get
something wrong forgive me uh next one
along is 512 so when you add 9 to that
you get 521
and then the last one that i'm going i
think you'll see the point by this
by this value 2 to the power of 10 is
1024 so if you add 10 to that you get
1034.
okay happy times
so there you go this is 2 to the power
of y plus y this is the left-hand side
and now let's have a look at the right
hand side so this is going to be y
squared plus 2. so the first one will be
5 squared plus 2. 5 squared plus 2
that's 25 plus 2 so that's 27.
the next one is
6 squared plus two this is a bit easier
so i'm only doing one thing to y so six
squared is 36 so you add two to that you
get 38 the next one will be 49 plus 2 is
51. 64 plus 2 is
66. um
81 plus 2 is 83 and then 100 plus 2 is
102.
all right
so let's pause right there for a second
can you see why like i did you got to
this point you're like uh i i think i'm
going to stop i don't think there's any
point in me continuing with this uh you
know try and identify like maybe later
on i'll get a solution
and the reason is because as you go
let's have a look at the right hand side
first as you go upwards for values of y
you can see the right hand side is
getting bigger
because you're squaring a bigger and
bigger number and then you add two right
so you can see the squares underneath
there 25 36 49 64 and so on so this is
getting bigger
but it's not getting bigger as fast as
the left hand side is the left hand side
is growing bigger so much faster right
look at this 37 70 you're in triple
digits already 135 264 these guys are
still plodding along in double digits by
the time you've hit triple digits down
here you're in quadruple digits up here
and uh you and you these guys are never
going to catch up to each other right
you can see they're actually what we
would call this is they're diverging
these two sequences of numbers getting
further and further and further apart
now why is this well if you have a think
about it it's because
the left and the right hand sides the
the sort of core of each of each one
is is quite different
here you're squaring numbers this is
what we call this is one type of what we
call polynomial growth so it's growing
faster and faster and faster but it's
it's not growing that much faster right
compared to what we call
exponential growth and that's a word you
might have heard because you know we're
living through a global pandemic at the
moment thinking of people from the
future watching this and and wondering
like what google pandemic right uh we
are living through curved 19 at the
moment and we've seen places where
case numbers and infections rise like
they they will get so much faster
there's this very very steep curve and
it's what we call an exponential uh
growth situation
now even though this um this thing here
this squaring this polynomial growth is
fast it will never it will never catch
up to exponential growth okay and here's
the thing right um these are all like
these numbers are basically doubling as
you go you can see it's kind of like you
know
70 is about double 37. 135 is about
double 70. um yeah 1034 is about double
521 the only reason why it's not exactly
double is because of this little extra
bit here right if we only had
2 to the power of y then it would be
exactly doubled as you go along but
because you're adding this extra little
bit they're like double and a little bit
right
but you're doubling doubling doubling
doubling if i didn't lock in x equals 2
suppose i took the next prime number
which is x equals 3.
you wouldn't be doubling you would be
tripling every time you would be
starting with three and then you'd go to
um nine and then 27 and then 81 and then
200 and
81
243
729 it grows even faster
and so you know that kind of diverging
that i explained before it's going to
happen even faster and even more
obviously right
so this is my way of sort of concluding
um by seeing these numbers and sort of
understanding oh okay this this pattern
is going to continue this one's going to
sort of race off and this one's
increasing but but not as fast right
this is how i'm concluding i i don't
think this is ever going to um sort of
come back together it's never going to
collide and you can try it out with any
base is what we call this x equals 2 is
that base number down the bottom
like i said try with any prime and
you'll see the same kind of divergence
happening
x equals 2 y equals 3 seems to match up
now i should point out um i've tried out
numbers i've sort of done this
substitution and you might say but eddie
you know what about you could try
numbers forever that's the thing about
numbers there's an infinity of them so
you could try out different combinations
and never get to the end of them one of
the ways one of the more technical
pieces of mathematics that i could use
to actually prove that for no value of x
or y these are ever going to you know
collide again is called calculus
calculus is the part of mathematics that
talks about how quickly or how slowly
things change
so it's about for example how how
quickly these numbers rise or how
quickly these numbers rise and the fact
that they will not ever um rise at the
same rate or one will never catch up to
the other and that area of mathematics
is one i've been trying to avoid talking
about in this video because i want it to
be relatively simple to understand and
comprehend
but let's just review right when we come
back to our original question
how many solutions are there well i
think that if you if you are allowed for
x and y to be the same number then
infinitely many solutions x and y um so
long as they are equal to each other you
will get this kind of pairing up
situation on the left and the right hand
side
but if you say x and y have to be
unequal they have to be distinct from
each other i believe that x equals two
and y equals three is the only solution
you'll find and no matter how far you go
for larger and larger values of x and y
um the left hand side and the right hand
side we want them to match up but they
will never match up they will get
further and further apart forever and
ever
so i hope you liked this little um sort
of foray into an interesting area of
mathematics if you have another way of
solving this i'd love to hear about it
but i hope that made sense to you and
that you learned something as you
listened and watched